So, I had the bilateral mastectomy, and now, I guess, in revision.
Praise God.
Is it pointless to research breast cancer?
Now, should I research preventative measures for lung and bone cancer since that's where
they come back to trusting God this will not occur?
I wouldn't research lung and bone cancer because when a cancer metastasizes, remember it's
still breast cancer.
So, I wouldn't research, I don't know that you need to continue to research, that could
just bring anxiety and I don't think that's helpful.
I think you continue to do the things that you're doing, don't change anything.
If you have questions about supplementation, make sure you either, you know, set up a call
with me or do another cheek swab, but you just, first of all, this question is did that
so you don't need to do that again?
You just, you are, there's a lot of trust, you're trusting that in God, whatever He has
is going to, you know, for you is going to happen and that you could accept that and you're
prayed, that it doesn't reappear or you're prayed, ultimately that whatever happens that
you're going to break in glory, that's the whole purpose of that.
So you just keep doing what you know to do, it's not going to really help you to do any
more research on breast cancer than you've already done, so I would, you know, just caution
you about that because that could be a spray boy inside.